foreign
there have been stories about what's
been happening to people who work at the
American Embassy in Moscow the stories
concern radiation first it was said the
Russians were either bugging or jamming
Embassy intelligence equipment and that
they were using microwaves to do that
and that that was getting Embassy people
sick to American Embassy employees in
Moscow may be suffering from cancer of
the lymph glands and that ambassador of
Walter stessel is suffering from
pernicious anemia Soviet Union has
admitted that some radiation exists but
the government newspaper is best you
dismissed it as ordinary non-dangerous
electromagnetic activity possibly caused
by the embassy there was no reason to
believe that those microwaves have
caused any Illness but U.S Personnel are
concerned over published reports that
the microwaves may have caused cancer in
a few cases Soviet technicians say
radioactivity levels in the U.S embassy
are at better than safe levels State
Department is considering taking
electronic eavesdropping equipment off
the Moscow Embassy roof so the Russians
will stop using microwaves to try to jam
it
asvestia said reports that the radiation
was caused by Russian snooping devices
are an invention with a foul smell
tornadoes last night and today killed
three persons in Arkansas
[Applause]
[Music]
I'm holding here a measuring instrument
and from the readings we can say that
the microwave radiation in this room is
I would say in biblical proportions or
astronomical proportions it's
approximately one million billion times
above natural background which we had
just 50 or 100 years ago so the
radiation levels nowadays are enormously
High compared to what cells have been
developed in
they are not part of the normal universe
that is a completely new type of
radiation
the beginning of the 1980s very few were
Electro sensitive but today it's well
over 10 percent I think and the trend is
pointing at close to 50 percent will
have one or the other type of
sensibility
within the next five ten years
how independent are the international
organizations that are supposed to
protect us
foreign
[Music]
I don't like to go into town anymore
because the radiation levels are so high
now so you feel it you feel symptoms I
think most people who become aware of
what this radiation might cause feel the
radiation quite quickly now
foreign
journalist I've written two books on the
issue of mobile phone health risks
my work in this issue started in 2002 in
connection with the massive rollout of
3G in Sweden quite immediately
discovered that the information from the
industry and the authorities was not
true in fact
there were already them a lot of
scientific studies showing that this
radiation could be a major health risk
the reason I wanted to investigate the
health effects of electromagnetic fields
actually go back to the
1970s and 80s and at that time in Sweden
there was an introduction on personal
computers and very soon people started
to report skin problems I still continue
trying to investigate the health effects
of various forms of man-made
electromagnetic fields
for instance heart rate variability when
you expose people to the microwaves what
happens then with the heart rate also we
had studies on the red blood cells and
the formations of clumps in the blood
and also to investigate the functional
impairment called Electro
hypersensitivity every human being is
Electro sensitive but the question is
will there also be people that are
Electro hypersensitive meaning that they
will pick up Fields signals whatever
that the rest of us doesn't feel and in
that way they will act like the
classical canary bird in the coal mine
they will react as biological sensors to
something the rest of the population so
far doesn't react to
[Music]
never
foreign
[Music]
okay
foreign
[Music]
comida
or Casino
is
everyone nowadays in all countries all
over the world are 24 7 whole body
irradiated wherever they are
foreign
so in that sense the whole biotope
everything living on the planet is at
Jeopardy they were not developed in an
evolution based on microwaves
the natural levels of microwave
radiation here on this planet are
extremely low
and suddenly we turn a knob and start to
send out and all these signals hit your
body go through your body and the
question is is it built for it and of
course it's not
these electromagnetic fields and waves
and signals they carry energy and it's
like pouring energy into any kind of
biological system you will have
alterations changes and of course cell
growth for instance and cell growth is
the same as cancer
[Music]
scientists has also shown that for
instance microwaves can destroy the
bonds in the DNA molecule which is the
basis of your genetic material and such
damages could be the starting point for
instance for cancer development so it's
very serious data
[Music]
El Uso is
no
foreign
unfortunately for the radio frequency
fields and for the mobile phones we are
in a situation of scientific uncertainty
I'm convinced we need more research at
the moment because everybody is is a
mobile phone users it's children using
it it's elderly using sick people using
it so we have to be certain and this
this demands more investigations
International Agency for research on
cancer is a research institution so we
are doing research and trying to
identify the causes of cancer
foreign
[Music]
Health Organization is responsible for
for policy so they are setting our
evidence that we find what causes cancer
and what doesn't cause cancer into
recommendations for prevention
the international Commission on
non-ionizing radiation protection this
is an independent panel that makes
recommendations on protection guidelines
for electromagnetic fields but they are
independent of both ayak and also who
foreign
[Music]
International Commission of experts on
this kind of radiation and ignip has a
huge power in this issue because ignite
has recommended the limits that most
countries at least in Europe have
adopted and as pointed out by themselves
they are only technical they were never
meant to be used as any kind of medical
safety or biological safety it's just a
technical measure but the governments
and parliaments and so on have used them
as a safety guideline and they are
definitely not and those limits are
based on an old Paradigm from the
American Military in the 50s that
considered that the only effects from
this radiation is are thermal when the
radiation is so high that it can hit
tissue limited is
[Music]
I started training in 1960
at the Royal Navy's microwave training
school
and it was my specialism throughout the
Royal Navy was looking at all aspects of
microwave Warfare
by the 60s it was mostly understood
some of the experiments done during the
Cold War that the scientists found that
they could cause
severe psychiatric problems like
changing the pulse frequency
imagine you are jumping on a trampoline
at your own bounce level and imagine I
weigh 56 Stone
and I jump on the trampoline and bounce
at my rhythm
you will be forced to bounce at my
rhythm
that is called entrainment and that is
what goes on when microwaves go into
your brain they change your own brain
waves because they are bigger and
heavier now depending on the pulse
frequency and the power can affect the
hearts pulse rates how the eye sees how
you hear bad behavior it can stop their
ability to learn how your brain will
operate
all of these can be done and they can
fool doctors
with that microwaves played a very big
part
in getting information during the Cold
War it was reported today that the state
department has sent a doctor to the U.S
embassy in Moscow to see if Russian
radioactive waves have caused three
people to fall well if you've been
microwaves at the window my talking
vibrates the glass
and the microwaves rebound back and if
you pick those up you can understand
what is being said so the Russians
microwaved the American Embassy to see
what Secrets they were talking about
but at the same time as the microwaves
were reflecting so the Russians could
hear they were also going through
and within 18 months they found that
the children had leukemia the women had
breast cancers
some of the men had Cancers and
virtually the whole staff had to be
changed tonight we have the first report
of a death among American Embassy
employees in Moscow who were exposed to
Soviet microwaves a secretary who worked
in the embassy between 1960 and 62
developed a mole on her face that later
became cancerous she died in 1968. what
I realized was that
some of the pulses
used by the communications industry
are exactly the same as the pulses which
are used for microwave Warfare It's not
the temperature that is a problem it's
the effects of the
electromagnetic waves on our system on
ourselves and the immune system and
everything
I have been working in Telecom area
since it started in 1966 and since
1987 I was within different companies in
Ericsson
when I was working in quality I saw a
graph
showing increasing rates of melanoma
skin cancer and we saw curves of
increasing failure rates of products
that was a big problem 100 million
sucrose for instance
foreign
Liga
say that the inner foreign
foreign
the protection guidelines we have at the
moment would protect you from any risk
that we have established
but whether for example you should
recommend unlimited use by children
that's a completely other issue and I
think even without strong scientific
evidence you should apply Common Sense
here and say it's a technology that we
have not fully understood it's it's a
technology that you hold directly to the
body
so we need to all work on this when we
talk about the reproductive system there
are a number of studies clearly showing
that male sperm cells are badly affected
actually and that they lose their
movement their capacity and their
morphology is destroyed and but the most
important studies may be on fertility in
the long term run where people have
looked on different generations of mice
and seeing that in the future after a
certain number of generations the
fertility was more or less completely
gone
and that is of course a very serious
warning signal and again I'm surprised
that
no one is really paying any real
attention to this what we are now
risking by microwaving the planets
we are saying we are prepared to risk
all of the future generations of the
world with genetic damage
for today's profit margin that is what
we're risking
and it's I'm not just talking people
the cells are identical to plants
animals humans
so if you're damaging a human cell you
are automatically damaging the plant
cells the pollinating insects over 200
of them they are all affected every
single thing
there are some very interesting studies
from India where they took mobile phones
and put them near to beehives and that
resulted in that bees left they moved
away
a bee will normally navigate using the
Earth's magnetic field
so what you have is a bee which is being
disorientated
and at the same time its immune system
is starting to collapse
foreign
if that would be correct
then we just have to stop radiating
these insects I mean that's crazy to do
it in that sense
[Music]
only the future will tell hopefully it
will turn out to be safe but that would
mean that thousands of scientific papers
all at the same time must be wrong and
that has never happened before in
history
[Music]
several long-term investigations
started that have been going on for
years
these long-term studies
seems to be just a way to push the
problem in front of you
get time to make as much money as
possible not to have to take decisions
today
it's just a question of when we should
start to react
in 2009
scientists met in Norway because
scientists felt that the ignib
guidelines were not sufficient to really
protect health and life and a special
pretty lengthy statement was published
and it was suggested that the current
guidelines should be lowered at least 50
to 60
000 times compared to the ignor
guidelines the authorities experts many
of them
know these problems but gives free space
for the technology for the industry to
use their systems
at least I suspect that this group
they are doing a job for the industry
[Music]
is
the commission is
[Music]
Industries
accepted an admittance that those limits
from ignip has been too high and that
there are health risks below those
limits is a serious threat also to this
industry there are lots of money
that have been invested in this system
thousands of billions of euros
the consequences to drastically just
forbid for instance mobile phones would
be drastic yeah
something
[Music]
is
foreign
[Music]
thank you
scientists from 14 countries have
reversed those years of reassurance
is
absolutely the classification of a
possible carcinogen is the weakest
scientific evidence we have so in the
future it with new scientific evidence
it can change in either direction the
general limb pattern I would say for
such warning signals is that they start
at a low level and then they move
upwards so most likely in a few years
time there will have been more data
collected and we will probably see and
an increase in the importance of these
cancer classifications
hopefully I'm wrong hopefully it will go
in the other direction it will turn out
to be without any risk but I would be a
little bit surprised then the World
Health Organization changed the cancer
classification mostly due to studies
showing increased risk of brain tumors
from mobile telephone use those studies
were made by la natural from the durable
University in Sweden
and also the interphone study the World
Health Organization 13 country study
that also showed increased risk for
brain tumors for mobile phones
I think that this radiation clearly
merited a higher classification because
there are a lot of evidence showing
cancer risk from this radiation the
problem is that the mobile phone
industry has dominated the cancer
research from this radiation so much we
have to make sure that that the industry
and the research is clearly separated
and of course I also think that the
industry has a responsibility to support
the research because they make all the
profit from the technology so so they
should be interested also in
demonstrating that the technology is
safe and what we usually do in practice
that we have a firewall between the
funding and the research so that there's
no direct link by contracts between the
researchers and the industry and that is
a mechanism that has shown to to work
very well and that is all
very well if if they had been
independent but
the problem is
the connections between industry and
these expert groups
album is considered to be one of the
world's leading experts in this field
and he's a professor at The carolinsky
Institute and he has led all Swedish
export investigations
into this issue
he has also been an expert to the World
Health Organization and he was part of
the igne expert group that recommended
the today's obsolete limits for mobile
telephony
I think that the conclusions
drawn by Anderson boom went through a
major change because earlier he was more
careful about what he said he didn't
clearly dismiss the risks as he does
today
and that is very strange
so there's been a major change and I
think
it is those conflicts of interest that
he has that can explain why he dismisses
the risks that he has clearly observed
himself
then I started to to to search further
and I then discovered that his brother
Gunner album had for many years
been a lobbyist for the major Swedish
mobile phone operator telia Sonora in
Brussels while Anderson at the same time
was a so-called independent expert for
many authorities in Sweden and also for
the European Commission
well the article about the conflict of
interest of andesh album led to his
non-participation in this expert
evaluation of the cancer risks and after
after that the mobile phone radiation
was classified as possibly carcinogenic
which probably would have not have been
the case if Android boom would have been
on this expert group
is
[Music]
foreign
and it turns out that if you read a
study anyone on random that say that
these techniques are safe they are
approximately four times more often
financed by the industry as compared to
studies saying there is a health effect
which I think is very sad in the sense
that already when they were started they
had lost a lot of their credibility
the months after the cancer
classification at the international
Agency for research on cancer and the
shelbon's colleague Maria festing at The
carolinsky Institute presented a study
was claimed to be the first study on
mobile phone use and ranging risk for
children
and it's a study design that we call a
case control study that was conducted in
four countries Denmark Sweden Norway and
Switzerland the indefined study did not
include any children or young people and
this is because the study has started in
the late 90s and it was very few
children that used mobile phones at that
time
claimed in the press release that the
study's result were reassuring but when
you look into the study and the
published results you see continuously
increased risk for brain tumor for
children who had had a mobile phone
subscription for the longest period when
you come to table four
you see here clearly that children who
had used a mobile phone who had had a
subscription for more than 2.8 years
they had more than doubled increased
risk of brain tumor furthermore when you
take a closer look at this study you
also see that they present result on use
of cordless phones when we started to
study children the cordless phones have
become much more common a lot of private
households had a cordless phone so the
exposure from the cordless phone also
becomes relevant but they don't disclose
clearly that they only studied the first
three years
of use of cordless phones this is only
mentioned in a footnote below the table
which is a quite strange
I asked Maria feisty if she could send
me a copy of the questionnaire that they
used in the cephalo study
she refused and then I turned to the
ethical board because I know that the
ethical board at the carolinska has to
accept
the study design including the
questionnaire
and I received the questionnaire a draft
questionnaire of the cephalo from the
ethical board
and it appeared that they didn't include
the strange restriction of the usage of
cordless phones to only the first three
years the child used it
this study is clearly manipulated you
you you can't imagine any serious
scientist
asking for only the first three years of
use
both the cephalo and the interphone
study that they show increased risks our
brain tumors for mobile phone users both
children and adults
so the results in the study when you
read them they show something totally
different than what is communicated to
the broad public
foreign definition
Alberto
we realize that the only sort of safe
rule here is that money is behind
everything it's always some political or
economical or industrial argument behind
the curtains that will drive a
development in certain direction this is
one of the most
economic powerful
today and it's not only about the
Telecommunications industry it's also
about the
defense and Military industry they also
produce microwaves they also use this
technology and they have the same
interests this is a military area move
away from the perimeter I say again this
is a military area move away from the
perimeter
foreign
this industry gives
the most to governments than any other
industry on the planet it can help the
government secret services
[Music]
you have to make up your own mind
because nowadays all these scientific
areas are heavily invested by other
arguments coming from politics economy
industry and so forth
so don't trust us trust yourself
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
ifu applications
if the precautionary principle would be
implemented in this particular field
most of these gadgets would immediately
be forbidden
is
and in this situation of scientific
uncertainty it's now the national
governments and their institutions that
are responsible for radiation protection
who have to decide of uh what to do in
this time period of scientific
uncertainty
as long as this health issue is off the
agenda it's very difficult indeed to get
any serious action taken by the courts
the courts really are not interested
because they see the international
commission and non-ionizing radiation
protection says there's not a problem
it sounds a very good name the
international Commission of dawn
ionizing radiation protection sounds
great and you think that's very
important but nobody knows how it's
elected how you're elected to it there
are no changes apparent changes to its
membership
I have a very good suggestion for I can
I would abolish it and uh I I think it
should be
people should be that are on it should
be accountable they should be elected
and it should come from differing
sources it should not just be a
self-perpetuating group which it is at
present uh and I know I've I've met with
many of them at stages I have a lot of
respect for them but it's there is no
patency and there is no even itself the
chairman of uh
palovich said well you know we are not
we shouldn't be regarded totally as just
the only guideline but they are
regardless the only guideline I consider
that those experts that are lying to the
public and to the decision makers about
what about what the science has shown uh
of course they should be held
responsible for for the for those lies
that they have produced during years I
think European actions is is perhaps the
best line to take on this I think for an
individual government to go for it is
more difficult but in the meantime I
think if companies or if areas are
unhappy about masks going into place or
schools are unhappy in terms of the use
of Wi-Fi then I think there should be
some attention paid to these concernsey
situation
is
[Music]
salus
is
unites
description
is crucial
responsibilities
foreign
decided
[Music]
[Applause]
no
Israel description
[Music]
my own husband has a malignant glioma
[Applause]
well my advice to everybody is to
investigate from himself to check the
evidence and to check the facts about
the the dangers of this radiation and to
try to reduce as much their own exposure
and
[Applause]
foreign
together in concert try to solve all
these issues they should go and find all
the scientific results themselves they
are readily available on the Internet
it's very very easy to find them some
experts say they're seeing evidence of
breast cancer that could be connected to
where some women keep their mobile
phones when you take something that and
put it directly on the skin it's high
energy microwave radiation for a
prolonged period of time in young women
with vulnerable developing breasts we
may have a perfect storm the the actual
insert that people never read frankly
that comes with the with the phone it
does say exactly that there's a the
Blackberry for example warrants to keep
your phone at least 0.98 inches away
from the body when transmitting if you
move it closer to your head they say
they can no longer guarantee that your
phone isn't emitting more radiation than
the FCC limit for every millimeter away
from the brain you get a 15 reduction in
radiation to the body they should read
they should think they should extract
the necessary information they should
mold it together to a decision boiling
down to their own private person
[Music]
[Applause]
see
foreign
terminated
communities
foreign
alternatives
the first recognition of Electro
hypersensitivity in Sweden was in 2000
these people with Electro
hypersensitivity
started to get governmental money
governmental funds to run their
different organizations and so forth
hello
okay
um
[Music]
okay
at
the haboria premiere
the Telecom branches at
this particular group has been extremely
badly treated and they have been
neglected and still are in most
countries and at many times they have
been really harassed
again
foreign
or the other type of sensibility
within the next five ten years so we
will see if we
get over 50 sensitive then we can start
doing something
[Music]
foreign
normal
area foreign
[Music]
foreign
classification and it's a great
deception that there has been no steps
towards authorities or mobile phone
industry recommending people to take
precautionary measures to handle this
radiation instead nothing has been done
business goes on as usual
people are not warned about the cancer
risks
children are increasingly using this
technology
I think it's a completely Health
disaster going on and people are not
informed about the risks
mobile phones computers computer screens
and so on from a biological point of
view they are just toys they are not
life necessities and to have that kind
of a very harsh arguments and threats
and discussions about toys and that's
for me a warning sign really and if you
look around in the world today you do
realize that the needs are very very
different and the needs today is about
clean water clean air food that we can
eat without risk it's about love
compassion understanding respect and
they are very seldom actually on this
economic agenda Prime reward is growth
we should have more and more and more
and more of everything you know and
that's from a biological point of view
very odd and scary
foreign
[Music]
to those interested in this is simply
don't use your phone too much
I I am I have a mobile phone myself and
I'm using it most
to take pictures because it's a good
camera on it
[Music]
is
priority
if one wants to be really safe then one
has to go back to Natural background
levels
which were around like for 10 20 30 40
50 years ago you can have solutions that
are not dependent on radiation
and maybe in the future if you come back
in 100 years time then we will have a
completely other Society where the
progress has meant stepping backwards
and stepping backwards for life
this industry is considered to be so
important to society and to the economy
that we will have to have a lot of
victims
a lot of dead bodies on the table until
we take steps to reduce the risks and
the exposure
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]